[Música]
comúnmente creemos que la telepatía es
el poder humano de controlar objetos o
cosas con la mente
yo prefiero llamarlo ciencia y es que
justamente en la ciencia la que nos ha
permitido desarrollar un dispositivo que
no solo te permite controlar objetos con
la mente sino que también te permite
comunicarte suena loco no pues a lo
largo de estos minutos les estaré
contando cómo fue que lo logramos
desarrollar y no no ha sido un reto nada
fácil pero tampoco imposible
luego en aquello de corazón amante de la
playa la naturaleza y un apasionado
mochilero me encanta la tecnología los
ciencias los temas de ciencia
inteligencia artificial y todas estas
tecnologías emergentes de hoy en día
tienen toda mi atención pero si podemos
aplicar estos temas en cuestiones de
salud o mejorar la calidad de vida de
alguien sin lugar a dudas será
totalmente totalmente de mi interés
hace mucho tiempo cuando yo vivía en
oaxaca mi padre sufrió una enfermedad
crónico-degenerativa la cual de alguna
manera le destrozó sus nervios y le
generaba dolores muy fuertes y a pesar
de que mi padre tenía la posibilidad de
poder expresar sus dolores y de poder
decirnos lo que le incomodaba de poder
decirnos cómo se sentía y nos lo decía
con palabras con gritos con llantos y
demás era muy frustrante para nosotros
como familia el no encontrar la forma de
cómo poder ayudarlo esa frustración fue
la que hasta el momento me ha dejado
como la necesidad de desarrollar algo
para mejorar la calidad de vida de las
personas justamente a lo mejor no como
médico pero sí es hacer que su calidad
de vida sea mejor no es por esta razón
que en el 2017 decido estudiar la
maestría en ciencias de la computación
en el tecnológico de león en guanajuato
y pues algo mi impresión definición
normal hago exámenes cursos demás
logramos el acceso a la universidad para
poder titular nos nos exigen que
realicemos un proyecto de investigación
el cual vamos a desarrollar a lo largo
de dos años que es lo que dura la
maestría generamos una tesis de este
proyecto y posteriormente debemos
defender el proyecto para obtener el
grado en cuestión la dinámica de trabajo
es que los doctores el grupo de
investigadores que ya tienen en este
tecnológico nos presentan a todos los
nuevos estudiantes las propuestas de
trabajo con las que ellos están que
ellos están realizando
había temas muy interesantes realmente
muy muy interesantes justamente en el
área tecnológica
de diferentes áreas pero no había uno
que sintiera yo que me apasionaría
completamente para realizarlo o que
tuviera como me interesa decir yo quiero
hacer esto y es que yo decía si voy a
dedicar dos años de mi vida a investigar
y a trabajar pues yo espero que estos
dos años sean algo que me apasione y que
pueda mejorar que pueda aportar algo a
mejorar la calidad de vida de alguien y
empiezo a platicar con los doctores ya
preguntarles si yo podía proponer mi
proyecto y obviamente me preguntan cuál
era el proyecto no sé qué es lo que voy
a hacer
entonces divagó y empiezo a pensar qué
es lo que tengo que hacer qué es lo que
me gustaría hacer y me doy cuenta que
soy una persona que habla demasiado
demasiado y aparte soy muy expresivo
todo lo digo si algo no me gusta si
tengo hambre si me duele algo todo lo
expresó y entonces dije ok mi papá podía
expresarnos lo que sentía y una sin su
vida fuera bastante complicada pero
ahora qué pasa con las personas que no
pueden expresar sus malestares mi papá
me decía me duele y le damos masajes o
le compramos una pastilla pero alguien
que no puede expresar esto tiene que
soportar estado o cualquier incomodidad
que tenga sin probabilidad que lo
pudieran apoyar
entonces se me ocurre que podemos hacer
un traductor de pensamiento a texto y
suena muy bonito y waha pues así lo
podemos hacer práctico con los doctores
y me dicen brother yo creo que estás
loco esto no se va a poder ya no
conocemos el cerebro estamos a años luz
de que esto ocurra
platico con la doctora rosario baltasar
una investigadora de esta universidad
ella trabajaba justamente con líneas de
la salud pero más en el área de confort
12 habitaciones inteligentes y siempre
pensar en el bienestar en el confort de
los pacientes hospitalizados le practicó
mi idea me dice que las dejé pensarlo
porque obviamente puede ser un tema
nuevo para todos ellos
empezamos a no le doy el tiempo de que
ella pueda como discernir si va a
trabajar conmigo si le interesa trabajar
conmigo y si le interesa el proyecto que
propongo ya después me dice sabes que
vladimir por hacer que tu proyecto son
señales y yo creo que como matemáticos y
científicos podríamos a lo mejor hacer
algo entonces pues hay que darles vamos
a registrarlo y trabajamos en eso
qué ocurre que algo mi protocolo de
investigación reportó al proyecto lo
registramos empezamos a hacer como la
revisión de la literatura ver que había
que no había que se podía hacer como lo
podemos solucionar y entonces empiezan
los problemas porque de entrada no
conocíamos el cerebro y en el grupo
académico eran puros cómputo logos
electrónicos entonces no tenemos como es
trabajo este fundamento médico que nos
pudiera como orientar por donde
desarrollar las las ideas o por dónde
abordar el problema y adicional a eso
tenemos del conflicto de que para poder
obtener las señales del cerebro
necesitamos una diadema de
electroencefalografía la cual tiene un
costo bastante elevado y el cual no
podríamos solventar o sea no contábamos
con los recursos para solventar este
este costo no
linda grande practicando con personas
científicos neurólogos psicólogos nos
decían así como de alta está muy bonito
y fondo muy ambicioso pero lo veo
complicado de que de que lo logres
porque ni siquiera nosotros que nos
dedicamos al área conocemos al cien por
ciento el cerebro
entonces yo te sugiero que mejor lo
dejes por la paz pero dejarlo por la paz
no era una opción porque para este punto
mi proyecto ya estaba registrado y sólo
tenía dos opciones o desertaba de la
maestría y abandonaba el proyecto y
perdía la posibilidad de graduarme de
una maestría y tiene que reembolsar lo
que daba con una deuda de la beca que
había recibido o tener que terminar mi
proyecto como diera lugar y entonces
decidimos terminar el proyecto como
diera lugar
la doctora rosario un día me dice sabes
que vladimir yo tengo un juego no sé
cómo funciona y no sé si te sirva pero
este juego de tal marca y lo que hace es
que te conecta con una diadema en la
cabeza tiene como un sensor citó y si te
concentras tuvo una pelotita si te
desconcentras la baja iba como saltando
obstáculos quieres verla para que las
revistas
no perdemos nada realmente hay que
revisarlo me entrega la diadema la
desarmamos empezamos a ver fabricantes y
demás y nuestra sorpresa fue que esta
diadema contaba o cuenta en su interior
con un tensor de electroencefalografía
el cual es desarrollado justamente por
una empresa que se dedica a esta área y
que adicional a ellos pues tiene como el
respaldo científico no de que si podría
ser funcional
en este momento veíamos como una señal
de que lo vamos a lograr si lo vamos a
hacer porque el lunes que teníamos la
forma de obtener las señales el exterior
alex y el otro reto es ahora donde
conectamos está esta diadema el cerebro
apretar de su pequeño tamaño procesa
cantidades enormes de información y no
tenemos una parte específica noticia
sabes que si te conectas aquí en esta
parte del cerebro específico aquí va a
salir el habla y aquí vas a sacar todas
las palabras tomando en cuenta que todo
lo que hacemos lo que vemos lo que
escuchamos cualquier cosa está generando
pulsaciones en nuestro cerebro
pulsaciones eléctricas que de alguna
manera se convierten en ruido el hecho
de que yo mueva una mano de que voltea a
ver de que camine de que esté pensando
en cosas está generando pulsaciones
eléctricas en el cerebro
entonces seguimos investigando y
decidimos colocar el sensor del
electrodo arriba de la ceja izquierda
basados en el sistema de medición
eléctrica monografía 1020 y el cual nos
indica que en esta parte podemos obtener
señales de concentración de meditación a
nivel de qué tan dormido que tan
despierta está la persona
y también como que tan hiperactivo no
que están alerta está tu sentido de
alerta y porque decidimos tomar esta
parte pues bueno
si nosotros nos concentramos mucho en
una actividad hay un mayor nivel de
concentración y un mayor nivel de
pulsaciones eléctricas que pusimos y va
a ser más fácil de poder extraer en
donde desarrollamos un protocolo de
experimentación el cual lo conectamos
habíamos mencionado y empezamos a
extraer las señales que nos estaba
brindando el electrodo para lograr que
el electroencefalograma
para nuestra sorpresa este
electroencefalograma nos da las señales
de cuatro frecuencias alfa gamma beta y
theta que por sí sola lo que hacen es
saber qué tan dormido tan despierto está
saber tu señal de alerta saber tu nivel
de concentración y tu nivel de
meditación a través de frecuencias no
entonces dentro del entrenamiento ya
tenemos a señales que genera una serie
de algoritmos para eliminar todo el
ruido que esto pudiera generar o sea
todo el ruido del cuerpo humano natural
no el ruido que estamos viendo el ruido
de lo que estamos escuchando el ruido
del latido del corazón todo tenemos que
eliminarlo para dejar la señal que hacía
referencia a las palabras que a nosotros
nos interesaban a la actividad que nos
interesa de alguna manera extraer
y para lograr esto se le hacen preguntas
al paciente preguntas con respuesta muy
obvia para un si preguntas con respuesta
muy obvia para uno tarda 12 minutos la
experimentación a partir de ahí se
obtiene una una base de datos y esto se
meten en un algoritmo de inteligencia
artificial el cual va a aprender cómo se
comporta el cerebro humano cuando piensa
en una palabra y cuando piensa en la
otra y después de esta etapa viene la
etapa de entrenamiento en tiempo real y
este es el momento más emotivo e
importante porque es justamente aquí
donde tú le haces preguntas al paciente
y el paciente le responde solamente
pensando así tal cual solo con el poder
de su mente tú le puedes preguntar si
tiene hambre si tiene sed si le duele
algo o si está incómodo si hace calor si
hace frío si te quiere lo que quieras
mientras la respuesta sean sí o no y el
paciente te las va a responder pensando
entonces para este punto estamos
extasiados de lo logrado porque
realmente era muy satisfactorio poder
haber encontrado una forma de brindar
esta alternativa de comunicación y lo
mejor de todo es que era accesible
económicamente
y que no requeríamos de como más más
capacidades de las personas donde el
paciente solamente que pudiera pensar
que estuviera consciente de lo que
ocurrió a su alrededor y que el paciente
pudiera ver o escuchar no necesitábamos
más
y hay otros trabajos de investigación
que antes han intentado de alguna manera
el traducir el pensamiento a texto sitúa
la universidad de bremen en alemania
ellos diseñan un proyecto al que llaman
brain reuters el cual lo que hace es que
habrá en el cerebro te abren el cráneo y
conectan una malla de electrodos
directamente en el cerebro y entonces lo
que obviamente con inteligencia
artificial pues intentan aprender cómo
se está comportando el cerebro cuando
estás produciendo palabras los ponen a
más palabras y entonces ochenta y ocho
de cada diez palabras se clasifican
correctamente pero ya cuando nos vamos
haciendo familias decrece un 60% la
clasificación correcta entonces está
bien para dientes hospitalarios pero es
demasiado costoso demasiado invasivo y
es que la verdad no me imagino alguien
por la calle con el cerebro abierto
y una malla de electrodos en su interior
no
en méxico tenemos el inaoe que ha
desarrollado un proyecto al que llaman
habla imaginada el cual justamente como
decía su nombre lo que lo que pretenden
es que te puedas comunicar sin hablar y
entonces utilizan un paradigma que
llaman potenciales visuales evocados
esto qué quiere decir que a través de la
vista y de las acciones de la vista el
algoritmo puede y saber la actividad
cerebral que se está procesando y
entonces asignan movimientos de los ojos
a palabras y volteó hacia la izquierda a
ver hacia la izquierda entonces a ok
quiere izquierda si volteaba a ver hacia
la derecha entonces el algoritmo dice
quiere derecha y también está padre
tiene una clasificación del 80% entonces
es bastante aceptable pero pues también
es como un tanto costoso y dependemos de
la vista del paciente para poder hacerla
la experimentación
platicando al proyecto y dando la
divulgación y demás un día me contactó a
un hospital de aquí del león y metió ya
sabes que tu proyecto me interesa crees
que lo podamos hacer o aplicar en
pacientes en coma
yo creo que si los requerimientos es que
esté vivo y que tenga conciencia
entonces después de trámites
burocráticos y demás logramos acceder a
un paciente en coma para hacer la
experimentación por tema de pandemia y
demás no hemos podido acceder a más
pacientes hasta este momento pero hay
resultados muy alentadores y que nos
indican que en algún momento muy
probablemente podamos comunicarnos con
un paciente que se encuentra en
situación de coma
imaginemos un panorama drástico donde
tenemos un familiar internado en coma al
que no podemos decirle que tanto lo
amamos al que no podemos pedirle perdón
por cualquier detalle al que no podemos
decirle preguntarle cómo se siente al
que no podemos preguntarle nada y saber
siquiera si nos está escuchando o saber
siquiera si es consciente de lo que
ocurre a su alrededor
si nosotros tenemos la oportunidad
desarrollar de aplicar este algoritmo y
este dispositivo para los familiares
sería sin lugar a dudas un cambio
drástico nos permitirá estar como más en
paz y más acercado a nuestros pacientes
pero no vamos a hablar de nosotros
hablemos de nuestro paciente
imaginemos que tú estás de participación
de coma estás encerrado en tu cuarto
contigo mismo tienes dos meses encerrado
en tu cuarto no puedes hablar con nadie
no puedes expresar nada no puedes decir
que te duele la cabeza si tienes hambre
si tienes calor si te quema la vecina no
puede decirle a tu ser amado que tanto
lo amas tanto puedes expresar nada es
frustrante de verdad entonces
trabajaremos seguiremos trabajando para
que el dispositivo que hemos creado sea
una realidad y cada vez más tangible y
así poder llegar a cambiar el mundo y la
vida de todas las personas que estén
pasando por esta situación
gracias
[Música]